the number of coronavirus cases in india
has officially topped
20 million as the crisis tightens its
grip
many experts believe that the real
figures for deaths and infections are
much higher than the official tally
at the same time supply shortages are
hampering the national vaccination drive
and the health care system is buckling
under the weight of new cases
there is no room for these patients at
this hospital
instead they are made to wait outside
and left hoping that the oxygen supply
will hold out
as ambulances queue at hospitals other
means of transport are also
taking on a crucial role trains are
india's lifeblood its tracks hauling
freight and people across the country's
vast landmass
today they also offer a lifeline this
locomotive pulls a precious cargo
oxygen headed to the worst-hit areas
india's railroads have been drafted into
the country's emergency response
in other ways too
eleven train coaches have been converted
into isolation wards
there's a separate coach for the doctors
that's 12 isolation coaches available
here
there are two oxygen cylinders in each
coach and we've set up
nine air coolers as well sprinklers on
the ceiling control the temperature
16 patients can be accommodated in each
coach and sanitation waste disposal
arrangements
have also been made ingenuity and
improvisation
are doing that bit to stem the rising
tide of coronavirus deaths
but it's not enough to shield the modi
government from anger over its failure
to prevent
this deadly second wave of the pandemic
it was a contributing factor to an
unexpected loss for the prime minister's
bjb
party losing an important state election
in west bengal
much like the surge in infections this
is not what modi had in mind when he
declared the
end of the pandemic at political rallies
all over india
after this miscalculation his political
fortunes
may be linked to the coronavirus more
closely than ever
and for more let's bring in dw's delhi
bureau chief
amrita chima amrita 20 million
infections reported in india how are
authorities trying to reverse the surge
hi sarah yes 20 million new infections
in the country a painful milestone
for india now the government is trying
all it can
to curb this surge it's the second wave
that india is now
seeing uh it's doing this through
restrictions lockdowns curfews
in many parts of the country including
here in delhi in fact
in one bit of hopeful news the number of
new infections in the past 24 hours
fell in delhi to the lowest in about 20
days
so of course authorities are hoping that
this is to do with the lockdown
that we have here in delhi the second
plank serra that the indian government
has in trying to curb the surge
is vaccination they started this in
january
and now they've expanded the vaccination
program to include anyone
who's over the age of 18. so the
vaccination program has got underway in
delhi yesterday some
40 000 uh people between the ages of 18
and 44 came out
and this is important sarah because a
lot of young people are getting infected
during the second
surge
and you know even still though amarito
we're hearing about severe shortages of
vaccines in fact
and people wondering how is that india
one of the world's biggest suppliers of
vaccines is in this situation
in fact yes you're right many of the
states in india are complaining about
shortage of vaccines
that they don't have enough to get this
new phase of the vaccination program
underway
that people over 18 can get vaccinated
now india has the world's largest
manufacturer
of vaccines that's in pune the serum
institute of
india now that played a critical role
along with another indigenous
vaccination uh company during this
vaccination
program but it seems that indus
underestimated its own need
after the end of the first surge it
began sending vaccinations overseas
as part of its vaccination diplomacy
some 66 million doses
were sent to dozens of countries and now
it finds itself in a position where it
doesn't have enough vaccine for its own
people
so they've stopped that program but they
also started trying to get vaccines from
overseas for example
russia's sputnik v that's now also being
used
in india's vaccination drive dw brussels
bureau chief
excuse me delhi bureau chief amrita
chima thank you so much for joining us
well now to some other developments in
the pandemic sri lanka has
imposed tough new restrictions in an
effort to contain the spread of the
virus
public gatherings and weddings are
banned and schools will remain closed
until further notice
cambodia is set to lift its lockdown in
the capital phnom penh despite another
record rise in daily cases
the country is battling its worst
outbreak to date
and north korea has warned its citizens
to brace for a prolonged struggle
against the virus
the u.n has earmarked nearly 2 million
vaccine doses for pyongyang but
it's unclear how and when those
shipments will arrive